robinson lleva varias horas de espera en
su camión en pacora una zona rural
ubicada a 40 km del centro de la capital
el paso por donde se dirige a entregar
gasolina está bloqueado por las
protestas desde hace dos semanas en sus
15 años como camionero no recuerda haber
vivido una situación similar pero la
prueba no te culpa de nadie puede nadie
que no echemos la culpa a nadie ya le
digo yo estoy totalmente de acuerdo de
lo que está pasando es importante porque
necesitamos
sube el gobierno y baja gobierno y es la
misma cosa
ellos entre ellos todo está bien entre
el humilde acabado lo que decir nosotros
lo que forman de la clase - de la clase
media es lo que nos perjudica entretanto
a 300 metros hacia dónde robinson se ha
quedado bloqueado alexis no que era
adoptado por ser carretillero para
transportar productos de un lado al otro
cuando iniciaron las protestas trabajaba
en una ferretería pero al perder ventas
por el cierre de vías quiero desempleado
la gente quiere que se acaben porque
también trabaja yo también quiero
trabajar hoy para ahorita mismo la
carretería no parece tal cual como mis
tíos
y eso
pero trabajar y seguir adelante lejos de
los rascacielos citadinos kevin sánchez
junto a otros indígenas no me google
mantienen el bloqueo como parte de las
protestas en todo el país aunque a
varios de ellos les ha costado su empleo
no renunciarán a la manifestación de
calles con nuestra responsabilidad lo
pudimos dejar a un lado nuestras
familias no podemos dejarnos a un lado y
vinimos a luchar en la calle defender a
los pueblo panameño que hoy ellos lo
están viendo otro punto de vista que la
manifestación han afectado a ellos que
estamos creando un problema pero el
objetivo de esto es que ellos al final
van a ser beneficiados si hay una
respuesta positiva aunque
momentáneamente se flexibilizan los
cierres para dar paso a personal médico
y productos como alimentos o medicinas
se estima que hasta ahora estos bloqueos
que se repiten en al menos 10 puntos a
lo largo de todo el país han causado
pérdidas económicas que superan los 500
millones de dólares